hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i want to give you the
five
habits that i applied to my life that
helped me become
a multi-millionaire so i'm gonna go for
a little walk it's snowing outside which
is fabulous
uh i can't go far because my wife is
very pregnant
and um how pretty are you um very
pregnant
nine months ready to pop anytime right
yeah so if i go for a long walk
by the time i get back um yeah i could
have missed
the baby so i'm gonna go for a very
short walk this is like a deja vu this
is our third kid
and i'm gonna circle around the house
and give you the five habits
that i have used to help me become a
millionaire if you like the channel do
me a massive favor subscribe
smash the like button drop a comment
below maybe there's a sixth habit that
i've forgotten which you can let me know
in the comments as well
here's what the first one is and this a
lot of people say this and you've heard
this probably before but it's so
vitally important i'm gonna give you
some actual practical applications of
this
but you do need a really positive mental
mindset
you need to see the best in every
situation like today for instance it's
snowing now to me this is amazing i'm
like oh my gosh it's snowing i want to
go out i want to go for a walk
but to some people they're like oh it's
snowing that's a nuisance look the
snow's on my car
and now i'm gonna have to wipe it off if
i want to leave the house and but
you have to see the best in every
situation and if you want to be a
millionaire
you've got to be able to see the best in
every situation because if you don't
if you what you focus on expands and if
you focus on the negatives of life
then you're going to have more negatives
in your life if you focus on the
positives
namely helping people making money
having fun being happy having a thriving
business
and that's what's going to expand i mean
i crashed my car
i was on on my way to a viewing you
can't really see it look it's so much
worse than that in real life it doesn't
look that bad
um 126 thousand pound car really nice
i love my car and then someone went to
the back of me while i was on the way to
a viewing
um a few days back and i could have been
like oh that's so annoying
but in fact i was just thinking well hey
i'm glad that i'm glad that i'm not hurt
i'm glad that um i'm on my way to a nice
viewing
there's hopefully i can make some money
on this house which will pay back for
the car so you've got to firstly have
a really positive mental mindset second
thing as well
which is also really really really
important is other people okay you can't
be
spending too much time thinking about
what other people are saying
other people are gonna have a lot of
opinions other people are gonna say a
lot of things about you about your
business
and in order to thrive in order to be a
millionaire
in order to be a multi-millionaire you
just can't be
holding on to the opinions of others you
know think about it right if you are
working at the moment nine to five and
you're an employee
and you decide you wanna be a
millionaire i mean what do you think
your colleagues are gonna say
do you really think they're gonna go
good for you and you're gonna leave your
job and you're gonna start working your
way up in your business and everyone's
gonna be
you know around you supporting you and
great no of course not
because they don't want to they don't
want you to leave them
they don't want you to succeed them they
want to keep you in
the bubble they want to keep you
protected they want to keep you safe
so other people and that's that's your
friends
i mean jesus if you're friends there's
my little girl
hi ruby she's camera shy
um if your friends say that just think
about the people that don't like you
what are your enemies gonna say
they might think i don't have any
enemies but again if you start making if
you want to be a millionaire
and your competitors are they gonna are
they gonna love you are they gonna think
you're great
no they're gonna try and pull you down
they're going to try and
stop you they're going to say things
about you they're going to say things
about your family
they're going to say things that aren't
true and you need to be really really
confident in yourself and you need to
have people around you
that know who you are that know what
your business is about that know your
heart
because you're gonna have a lot of
opinions and the second habit
that i really applied in becoming a
millionaire was
not caring and not listening to what
every single person
on the internet or every person that
didn't have my best interest at heart
had to say about me you know their
opinions so that's the second thing
next okay in fact this is actually an
acronym this is polos so the first one
is positive
second one is opinions next is l and
that's love what you do
you've got to love what you do if you
don't love what you do
then it will feel like a job and if
you're trying to become a millionaire
believe me you're going to have to work
a lot of hours you're going to have to
put
blood sweat and tears into your business
and it is going to get really hard and
if you don't
love it like i'm my business is property
real estate so i buy houses
i develop houses rent them out um
build houses sell houses flip houses all
things property
but i love property i love restoring
properties
i love i love providing family homes for
for young families
common affordable accommodation i love
the interior aspect my
wife is a quantity surveyor and has got
background also in design
um we love the business love love love
it and because of that
it doesn't feel like i'm working on a
a business or a job it's just i just
love it it's a hobby to me
it's a hobby that i am absolutely
obsessed with
and and i say if you love what you do
you'll never work another day in your
life again so make sure
if you want to be a millionaire make
sure that you get into the habit
of doing things that you love doing if
you don't love doing it you can
outsource it which we're going to get
onto later so love it love it love it so
polos
positive mental mindset opinions don't
care what other people say and think
um love what you do and next is
um outsource everything i was just i was
just saying this a moment ago
outsource everything replace yourself
make yourself redundant
if you want to be a millionaire you're
not going to be able to do it by
yourself
and trying to do it by yourself is
extremely lonely so what you're going to
have to do is you're gonna have to get
other people
around you you're gonna have to have a
an operations manual
so everything that you're doing in your
business all the jobs
all the activities write them down write
down a guide
a training manual of how to do it and
then constantly
replace yourself now i'm not just
talking about your business activities
i'm also talking about your everyday
life like
your garden i mean jesus if i had to
maintain
a home it would be probably a part-time
job just cutting the lawns and
cleaning and but we outsource our lives
we outsource everything not just in our
personal lives but also in the business
professionally everything is outsourced
so that
i as a millionaire can just focus
on doing the things that are millionaire
activities
you know i don't want to be doing
10-pound jobs like cutting the cut in
the garden and cutting the grass
and cleaning the house and you know
admin activities and bookkeeping
when i could just pay somebody 10 20
pound an hour to do that
and then i can focus on actually working
on the business rather than just in the
business
so have a manual write down all the jobs
that you do
write them down and then put turn that
into a training manual
um and teach your staff for the first
member of staff will probably be an
assistant and you'll be able to say look
i've got this little manual
and you'll be able to teach the
assistant all the jobs that you
can pass them so outsource your life
outsource everything
and then lastly is s and this is
honestly one of the most important
things
um and that is be grateful for the small
things in life the small things in life
never despise the small things um
what do i mean by this well i'm talking
on a personal business and
um ev every every which level i i i can
think of because
like literally if i'm out in the park or
i'm out i'm out
um in the garden with my kids um
we've got a little trampoline you can't
see it here you know i'll just be like
grateful for the small things just being
able to just spend
20 minutes out in the garden they say
that sometimes
the best you know the best things that
happen in life are actually the
free things i mean they may as well cost
the earth if you haven't got the time to
enjoy them
but you can do so much small things for
free which is really fun you don't
realize that actually they're the big
things later
so don't ever despise the small moments
the fun little things in life
um with your family and also money as
well
i mean if you are faithful with the
small
that you've got the small amount of
money then you'll be given much more
that's a biblical a biblical principle
and
i think it's very very very true you
know if you think i've only got a little
bit of money i'll start managing my
money properly
i'll start investing it properly when
i've got more money
no you need to be faithful with the
small
the small moments the small money oh you
know what i know i let that person down
i was late for them but it's not really
important because it wasn't an important
meeting
no it was a meeting be faithful with the
small
and how you do anything is how you do
everything so
it's really really important to remember
that you have to start somewhere
it starts with the small moments in life
um
and even small amounts of money if you
think and this goes back to positive
mental attitude as well if you've got
only a hundred pounds in your bank
rather than thinking i've only got a
hundred pounds
just just actually be grateful for the
small and say i've got 100 pounds
you know that's 100 pounds more than a
lot of people at the moment
um and then and then put that to use
invest that i mean when i started out
i didn't have any money at all i started
out with nothing um
and i'm gonna be faithful with the small
now because my family are just joining
me hey
you guys ready they're all camera shy
today
so i'm gonna be faithful with this small
right now my family we're gonna go and
enjoy the swings
and um and just remember that these are
the five
habits to becoming a millionaire and and
these are habits because they're
choices i hope you found this video
helpful if you did
subscribe i do a video every single day
uh sometimes a small video but always a
powerful video and
um anyway guys happy new year i know
we're kind of
almost february now um i'll have a
wonderful 2021. god bless